Marrakech in rocco is at 44 degrees and
Seville in southern Spain has seen 41.
over in Italy Sardinia is expected to
reach 36 degrees while Monopoly will tip
in to the 40s
now in Greece in Athens they've seen 37
degrees from where our climate and
energy correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
reports
the Acropolis in Athens baking in the
heat
thousands of tourists still determined
to see this famous site despite
temperatures pushing up towards 40
degrees
some are already regretting it we're on
a cruise ship actually so I probably
would have just stayed on a boat today
had anyone it would be this hot it is
very unpleasant yeah but um especially
coming from somewhere like Ireland you
know where it is so cold and damp all
the time and then you just hit this heat
and it's hard to cope with the Hellenic
Red Cross are trying to help handing out
water setting up shade tents dozens of
people have needed medical attention
today because of exposure to the heat
that's why the vulnerable have to be to
stay at home and not go out elderly
pregnant woman children who have things
that happen we have people that are not
feeling well
conditioned community centers then a
Lifeline for some
here is an oasis it says Demetrius the
cooling center is an oasis for the old
people
come here because it's a very pleasant
Place says ago
at my place it's very hot
a picture that's being repeated
elsewhere these brutal temperatures
aren't just affecting Athens or even
just Greece much of southern Europe is
in the grip of a heat wave and it's
threatening records and potentially it's
going to last for another two weeks
conditions have led to wildfires on the
dalmatian Coast in Croatia residents and
tourists evacuated as firefighters
battle the flames
in Italy major cities remain under Red
Alert for Dangerous Heat
and in Spain they are expecting another
surge in temperatures next week
the Greece's minister of climate change
and civil protection it's time to accept
a new reality Greece Italy
the northern part of Africa turkey is
not anymore climate change when the face
of a climate crisis we are going to have
fires we are going to have floods we'll
have to deal with uh what is happening
increasingly frequent and increasingly
severe weather events the Hallmark of
climate change and here to stay
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Athens